on his first full day as president-elect
joe biden did what is for him at the
core of his life
a mass at the church where his first
wife son
and daughter are buried his religious
faith as america knows
guides their next president victoria and
karen have known the bidens for years
and they know what this place means to
him we always stop by
beau's grave joe's son beau whenever
we're
in the neighborhood and then we realize
that joe must be at mass because of
all the press that's here and so we just
decided to
to walk out and maybe hopefully see joe
this morning i think that it means
everything to him
and i think it gives him the strength to
do this because i don't think his heart
was really in it
when he started because of losing bo
because of losing beau but
he knew he he knew that that
beau would have wanted him to do this
[Applause]
it was on a stage in his hometown of
wilmington with a nation watching
that he and his vice president-elect
have presented themselves as america's
future
and healing division means reaching out
to those who supported the man he beat
people of this nation have spoken
they've delivered us a clear victory
a convincing victory a victory
for we the people
we've won with the most votes ever cast
from presidential ticket
in the history of the nation the
election of kamala harris a woman and a
woman of color to the white house
is a first that is hugely significant
for this country
while i may be the first woman in this
office
i will not be the last
because every little girl watching
tonight
sees that this is a country of
possibilities
they were listening all over the country
not least on the streets outside the
white house
celebrations among those yearning an end
to the trump hero
the sitting president headed for the
golf course again he'd spent his sunday
morning tweeting
he continues to allege election fraud
while providing little evidence
twitter keeps adding the warnings it is
likely to end up in the courts
and republicans who are no allies of
trump don't expect him to go quietly
we're not going to change president
trump or his nature uh
in the waning days of the presidency and
so
i i don't think i'm going to be giving
him advice as to what to do the
president's going to do what he
has traditionally done what he's doing
now i don't think that's going to be a
surprise for anybody
but joe biden's not waiting for donald
trump his administration has already
launched a new website the transition
team is working
and tomorrow they'll unveil their own
coronavirus task force
joe biden knows the celebrations are
over and this is a country in crisis
joe biden has urged his supporters to
keep the faith whatever challenges to
his legitimacy he faces
he's achieved his ultimate political
goal and the hard work
is only just beginning greg milam sky
news wilmington in delaware